awesome thank you uh yeah it's really
it's really cool to see all these uh
all these chat messages from people all
over so very neat to have a
diverse diverse group um join in today
uh yeah i guess uh the caveat here is if
you do a message rachel uh just don't be
surprised if uh you got roped into doing
one of these
so um but uh no i
i joke um i'm super happy to talk about
um some of the stuff that i do um and i
guess
without further ado like you said uh let
me just
share my screen here for uh this
presentation
uh one thing i'd say is that i probably
won't be able to see the chat
so uh i might not be able to
answer anything that comes up inside of
there as we go but uh hopefully we'll
have some time
at the end to talk through uh you know
whatever is going on
um or whatever i can read them out to
you too so you don't have to worry about
oh and and mike will share the slido
link in the chat window
and so then people can upload questions
too cool
incredible awesome well um i guess let
me just get started can everyone see
this
looks great great i see some modding so
uh that's
i think that was a good sign um great uh
so i guess um
uh let me just really quickly introduce
myself
so my name is mathias i'm based in
nashville
um i've been in nashville for around
about seven years now but i'm actually
originally from germany
so i kind of took a very odd detour into
the united states
[Music]
on a personal level i've been married
for just 10 years now i had my 10 year
anniversary
earlier this year and then i have two
kids
one of them is actually turning six uh
next week so
it's a big one in this household
currently and then i have a two-year-old
his name is adam um on a professional
level as rachel said i uh direct the
marketing analytics team at campaign
monitor
and also moonlight as like a teacher
at the nationals office
profile there's a bottom uh feel free to
connect
i'm happy to talk about this
presentation or anything else
that revolves in or around data science
um i guess i would um it would make
sense for me to talk about campaign
monitor just for one hot second here
um so campaign monitor is a family of
brains
with campaign monitor or cm group
sort of being the parent and then we
have uh
several brands and products that fold
into that
um so there is actually the namespace
company campaign monitor
but uh we also own brands like emma
deliverer
celegen sail through and a slew of
others so essentially all uh
marketing technology companies and we
are sort of a bit of a conglomerate um
in offering different solutions to
different
um different types of marketers
so as a group where we'd like to call
us a leading market company we have
about 7 000 global customers
um and again those could range from a
very small business
uh you know that might just need like a
simple email marketing newsletter
uh type service
all of that fun stuff um just
uh that 180 billion there uh refers to
the
amount of emails that we've sent just
last year uh so that's the scale that
we're operating at
um you know uh for um on behalf of our
customers every year
uh campaign monitor is uh we're roughly
a thousand employees at this time
um and uh 90 of those are inside of the
marketing group on 90
some of them are in the marketing group
um
and then my team specifically is
actually fully embedded into that
marketing function
so i or my team serves as an
in-house agency or in-house analytics
agency
uh other companies might uh refer to
this as the center of excellence
so we're a function that serves
essentially stakeholders inside of
marketing
uh which is a lot of fun because it
gives us
a different analytical requests all the
time so
one day we could be working on
optimizing
uh something like the marketing mix uh
another day we could
uh build a lifetime value or work on the
multi-touch retribution problem
customer journey mapping um and
uh so it's really neat because it's a
diverse
uh set of problems that we work
work against on any given day
in order to do all this my team like
rachel's head is consistent of
a different a slew of different
functions so
there's a research insights engineering
and data science function
so i have loosely four groups um the
research team is
essentially is there to produce and
procure data that's not currently
available to us
and try to figure out how we can how we
can
make that data available um insights
is really kind of looks for more
traditional analysts
so they're really highly integrated into
the marketing function that they work
with
uh translating data into
insights for that person to uh you know
that might not have a technical
background
engineering uh i mean i guess
uh given the types of people on this
call it seems like it's fairly
self-explanatory
as well as data scientist uh data
science here but
um the twist for my engineering team
specifically is
um that it's uh sort of a purposeful
integration of
marketing specific data so we have
actual data
favorite between analytics and um
in engineering and all traditional data
engineering
and then last but not least data science
so this is actually where a lot of these
more advanced
uh projects happen so anything that
deals with
things like uh forecasting mms mtas
and so on uh would live in that function
um so that's a quick um
overview over my group um and at first
when um
rachel and i were talking about what i
should be talking about
um i wanted to actually speak
on like you know hey let me just pick
out a random projects here a project
here and i'll talk about like a model
that we built or something
um but uh i actually decided against
that in the end
uh and wanted to talk about something
more foundational um
so given the unique setup that we have
being sort of like an in-house analytics
analytics agency to the rest of the
marketing team
um i really wanted to talk about
adoption and making sure that things
that we produce on the data
data and um you know how do we actually
get people to utilize our stuff i i
also hopefully find that a little bit
more
translatable to like the greater group
here that might not all be in marketing
um so i think for um
uh data science specifically um you can
do
absolutely incredible work but
ultimately it comes down to
if no one's using that work then uh as
you know it doesn't really matter that
you did all of it um
so in our setup that actually can be a
specific challenge
um since we're working with so many
marketers of
different disciplines um and most of
them actually don't have like a quant
background
um you know like we could be working
with uh copywriters
from one team um so really today i
decided to
just talk about um how we're solving
that
and how we're solving that specifically
at campaign monitor inside of the
marketing function
um so um insert
in short um if i title this like how do
we actually
serve insights uh to the team uh using
automation and
or code so to say um
so to to talk about this a bit more in
terms of what the actual problem is i
already touched on that problem
there a bit but um really
level setting like who we are so we're a
global marketing technology company
we have an incredible amount incredible
amount of data available
so there's sales data there's website
data behavioral data
like i could keep going and that would
probably be the entire 60 minutes
of today um but ultimately we have this
treasure trove of data
um and uh the first instinct as a data
scientist is that this is actually a
really fantastic thing right i have a
lot of things i can analyze
um but we actually noticed that
specifically in our use case in our
specific setup
um that overabundance of data also comes
with a lot of challenges
so first um and this is a really big one
um so dashboard fatigue is a real thing
so uh
we uh as we scale and as we grow and
when i first started at campaign monitor
roughly three years ago
uh we were about the third of the size
than we are now
um it's becoming increasingly hard to
just build something in the eye push out
a dashboard
and have people utilize their business
intelligent
simply for the fact that you know it's
not a it's not a very scalable process
because you ultimately cannot expect
people to
um uh spend their entire day just
looking at dashboards um it's just
there's cognitive overload that happens
there
um secondly like the eye i think can be
really hard to digest
especially for non-technical people um
so
what i mean by that is um you know
if if i uh let's say i built a
visualization that's a bar chart of
revenue for example um you know like
everyone can hopefully understand what
you know like sort of like look at this
and
understand trends and see if it goes up
and down
but then lots of times uh that actually
misses the context of what's going on so
uh kind of giving people um
bi without um sort of guiding them
through what this actually means or
what's going on in the deeper level
and sometimes can be really can be a
problem for
us and then last but not least i
mentioned this bi there a few times so
we have uh we have a looker instance
so we we do utilize that pretty
extensively um
so we have you might call it
sophisticated business intelligence
available to us uh but that really
requires a stakeholder to be self-driven
um in many instances of price training
oh sorry
[Music]
was that a question too or uh i think
someone accidentally unmuted but
all right no worries but if it was a
question feel free to put it in
the slider yep there we go good uh
uh good segway um
cool well i guess uh in anything like
you know i can keep going i'm sure there
are actually more problems that
we had with the with the prior setup um
uh but i guess for now let's just leave
it at this
so ultimately if we want to democratize
data across the marketing organization
like we really needed to find a way to
serve
insights to people directly as well as
like in an easily digestible way
um and at campaign monitor uh we're uh
actually um using a slack bot for that
um so uh
i guess if i could you know ask for show
of hands like again i can't see anyone
here so
um um you know i'm just gonna pretend uh
show offense um that uh um uh how many
of
all of you are using slack uh i'd wager
to say that it's probably a good
proportion
uh i see tatsu uh raising your hand
actually it
just popped to the top um so uh uh
yeah um so ultimately um if you're
unfamiliar with slack
uh it's essentially a business
communication platform uh think of it
like it's like a
better better chat environment where you
can have
a direct message with all of your
colleagues
but you can also have uh group together
team channels
um where um you know you can collaborate
with your co-workers
uh scm um essentially slack has all but
replaced email internally so i only get
like a few emails
every day in fact um i actually enjoy
that a lot because
the only people that really email me are
outside vendors
so i can uh you know i can decide
whether or not i want to engage
on any given day with uh with outside
vendors because everything internally
usually happens inside of slack and uh
um for us that's really a huge
opportunity right like
because we know uh communication
collaboration
happens in this like centralized
location um
and we can we can use that to our
benefit uh which is what we're doing
with this slackbot
let's talk about slackbots for a moment
um uh
for those of you that are not familiar
with the concept of a bot
um so in layman's terms um a bot is like
any other user
um that you could have on a platform but
really it's a robot
um so it's a non-human uh um
user in this case and that that uh
bot can execute tasks uh as they're
programmed to do
um so in this like really silly example
here we could code a bot
that interactively listens to anyone
asking what time it is and it would just
respond with
like today is this it's that time uh
which you know even more preposterously
like slack actually puts the time
message there so
um like i this would be a stupid example
um but just to kind of like show what
this does
um you know if someone were to ask what
time it is
um the bot could listen for that and
then post the response
um to that specific indicator um
that's a simplified way of doing it um
there's a lot of different interactive
uh things you can do with slack but
that's
essentially how bots function there is
uh essentially two
they're not distinct types of thoughts
but i think of them
one uh uh an active bot like the one i
just described
um where you could have uh as the name
suggests
interaction with that bot uh so uh
you know there's things like slash
commands and um in stock
um but also like uh listening as well um
and then there's non-interactive bots
um which essentially just uh post
information into a specific channel or
group for this purpose here
i'm actually going to focus on the
non-interactive portion
um you know because i think that would
break the
break the scope of this presentation
but uh it's also uh uh useful because i
can hear monitor we actually
um uh use this non-interactive feature
quite a lot um to uh uh give people
information that they want
uh or uh um that we deem impo
important at that given time uh so our
campaign monitor we actually created the
slack bot called mr predicto
um this is kind of a silly joke a silly
inside joke so at one point we were
um building marketing forecasts and then
someone jokingly said like
can't we just have like an additional
predictor variable that we put in there
um that's just based off one of those
like kids fortune telling toys where you
just
bought the thing and it's just that's
like yes or no
um you know we didn't do it but like
that's ultimately how this mr predictive
thing was born because apparently
someone on amazon
sells this uh this thing called mr
predicto
and it's essentially like a kid's toy
fortune telling ball
um but we we did this um that is to say
that it's fully customizable you can do
essentially whatever you want with it
um you know all you have to do is uh um
uh use the slack api documentation
it's really well documented and it's
actually a really um
really easy to use
online graphical user interface that you
can use there
so once you authenticate this thing with
the slack credential and you add it to
your um
to your slack organization um you can
then move forward
with trying to understand or trying to
see how you can actually push data into
uh into slack
so um non-interactively the easiest way
to do that is using web hooks
um so uh that's a bit technical if you
don't know what web hooks are so
let me just go into that for a moment so
the easiest way to push data into slack
with to robot is using incoming web
books
um so web hooks are um
you know in i guess in simplified way
a way to push data into an api
um so an event in the most basic form
uh really in order to push data into
this web book
um you can in terminal you could curl
an example and essentially you have a
web book url that you that stock would
give you for each specified channel
so if you in slack and you uh
um uh you know you can select the
specific channel
that you bought should be should be part
of and then in the back end of slack api
you can look up what the webhook url is
for this specific channel
uh so in this case you know it returns
you this um
this ul which is what we call a webhook
url um
and then the other thing that this um
this specific
bot requires is uh just the payload um
in this case a json object no table uh
uh payload um where you know
sim simplistically essentially you can
pass in the text
that just says hello world you run that
and at that point the bot would actually
post
hello world inside of this channel
that's connected to this specific weapon
um now full disclosure here um i'm not
like a unix wizard
so to me uh that's sort of like the the
extent of what i would do in the
terminal uh because i'm much more
comfortable in r
the um httpr package
um has uh that is essentially a post
request to the api
so while the code here looks a little
bit different um i'm hoping that it
still looks a little bit familiar if you
think about like
what i just showed you on the previous
slide um
so um it's still going to have a
uh web workbook url right you you still
uh you still
post that same or you still you utilize
the same url
um where uh um you know you would just
paste in that
um that url that you that you've given
um and it still
requires a json payload it just kind of
uh is a bit different
in terms of formatting so in this case
it's wrapped into like a paste function
um that essentially just ends up
concatenating the whole thing um and the
reason why
it's written this way is that ultimately
obviously hello world alone isn't going
to cut it for me but i also want to
paste in you know maybe the output of a
variable
variable that i'm using somewhere else
inside of r
so uh functionally though this code here
uh does exactly the same thing
uh than what you would um than what the
previous slide did
so if i actually execute this so if i
run this our markdown chunk
um it would run it um and you would
actually get a bit more of a response
back so it just kind of summarizes that
response
this is a http uh
response uh code you can look here
the status of 200 in this case
means that it went through fine so 200
is like the response code for you yes
this this worked
um for those of you that might be in
marketing at marketing
uh a bit more you might be familiar with
like three or one uh
uh statuses or three or two statuses uh
which have to do with redirects and all
of those but
essentially this status code here is
really useful
um for you to understand if this didn't
work
um you know the status quo is usually a
really good way of telling
um why it didn't work most likely for me
it's 400 which means i formatted
something wrong
um and that happens all the time um but
you know again the status quo there
would help you figure that out
but once this executes what happens on
the slack slide is literally
it would do the same thing and post
hello world um so
obviously hello world uh kind of neat
little example but doesn't really help
anyone uh to just kind of post in random
text
um so obviously we want to extend that
past this like hello world um
uh example because it's a bit uneventful
um so if we want to do more stuff
um like there's actually a really great
blueprint inside of the slack um
api documentation um which is this black
uh bot kit builder or block kit builder
um where uh there's essentially a
graphical user interface
that allows you to um build your message
uh as you uh you know as you would like
to build it
and on the right side here it actually
tells you
uh the blocks of the payload that you
can use
to build this message so you could uh
you know and there there's a ton of
different things
available so you can use anything from
like buttons to images to
um links mark slack markdown notation
and it was just kind of give you an
example of um okay so if you build an
example here
on the right side it would actually tell
you uh this specific payload or the
specific json
object that you want to build inside of
r uh to then push into this report
so in in essence it actually becomes
really easy to build more sophisticated
messages
um and um to me
um that kind of really means that
there's virtually like endless
possibilities right
so um once you have this like initials
done like your environment
um there is so many there there's
so many things that you can do um at
campaign monitor
uh figured i've run through a few things
that we've actually done here internally
um so we've built like internal
notification systems
uh where we push uh insights into like
our own team channel so marketing
analytics for this is a
there's a locked uh internal channel of
my team
uh that highlights code breaks it looks
like anomalies and data
um it does uh basic automated reporting
for like some of the things that we're
interested in
uh we've built uh notification systems
for other teams so for example
um we have uh paid search forecasting
and anomaly detection for that so we
track
daily you know this might be a very
marketing focus here
um but like uh cost per click so how
much are we paying
for each click that we're buying on
adwords
um over time like is that deviating from
uh what we you know paid the last on
average
uh over the last few weeks like click
volume impression so essentially
um we we can do any anything that we can
like build a model against uh we can
ultimately push in the slack
and we have done that for like the
performance marketing team
uh in many instances and then
as actually as we started doing this
like internally inside of marketing
um it actually grew and grew um sort of
the
concept of no good deed goes unpunished
so
uh we essentially now have
organization-wide notifications that
we've built and put in place
um you know where we might be notifying
entire teams when
certain reports are available certain
data has been refreshed
um you know like monthly post mortems we
would write in like essentially a
ror markdown um and once that's
available
in the end it might shoot up a slack
with the link to it
so people can then end up or they can
they can use that
and get that information right where
they are so in short
really anything that you can envision
you can code in r
has some way of being pushed into islam
um it wouldn't be i guess it would be uh
um
uh not fair to actually not talk through
a specific example
so this is one uh um you know that i'd
like to talk about which
is actually something that's currently
still in production so we actually use
this
uh still even though this example here i
just put this random number of
um from december of last year but this
still runs every day
um and this tracks daily mql volume
uh again for those of you that might not
be in marketing um
mql is a sort of salesforce uh
uh terminology for marketing qualified
leads which is a
indication of how much uh how many uh
opportunities
um we're bringing in into the company um
uh that our sales team can hopefully uh
close for us um and in this case
the specific case um you know like one
thing that you could see here would be
that
like hey we're tracking uh you know
we're tracking
mql volume over you know for for
yesterday
we actually compare that against the
same weekday of the five
prior weeks so in this case um this
wednesday number here
um of like 19 mqls would have
compared or this this uh confidence
interval that's calculated
is essentially the prior five wednesdays
that it uses as input data and then
models are out where we feel like we
would be um so in this case
you know obviously this 19 number is
much higher than
like the even the top range of 11 that
we expected here
so um you know that's that's a way to
like
immediately notify of uh specific teams
of what's going on
um one thing that i'd love for you to
pay close attention
here um is that it actually just took
seven minutes
in this case um so again this is a true
screenshot here
uh it took seven minutes for people to
start talking about what was going on
um you know in this case we changed some
like a demo form there
uh made it a bit shorter and that that
um seemed to have
been the the thing that was driving uh
some incredible increases for us
um but uh uh you know that's that's
that's a use case of how we're using um
uh in this case anomaly detection um
to really kind of quickly gauge
performance and determine if
any action needs to be taken in this
case um
so let's take a look under the hood here
though
so if we have this message um
you know while it might look like a sort
of complicated message to send you know
you have
text or graphical elements there's like
this weird
uh um uh sort of quote
uh indent there you know there's
different uh
different formatting all of this um we
can like fairly easy to deconstruct this
um and let me actually do this here to
show what's going on a bit
so at first um
i guess to level set this assume that
there is a data frame somewhere
um that essentially stores the anomalies
that we detected
so i'm not going to go into like the
actual model of how we um
in this specific case build out or
identify anomalies um
because again that would probably be
outside of the scope of this
presentation but
um assume that that's there somewhere
um so in in in that sense
um if we deconstruct the message it
really kind of still
um works in a in a fairly simplistic way
right so this message that um posted
here
has a title so at the top here uh this
blue part
uh would be we called message title and
we stored this into this object
um uh called message underscore title
and we just paste together essentially
concatenate this entire thing
um to come out with like one long string
of things that actually leverages in
this case variables
um to paste out this um
this specific um uh
character string right or vector um
you can use uh if you're uh um if you
feel like you want to you can use
a slack uh markdown in it so
uh it's actually fairly similar to like
uh
how you would um um
how you would write markdown inside of r
so for example um
this asterisk here um and then it ends
um the asterisk closes here
which essentially between two asterisks
is it bolds text
so as you can see it says daily anomaly
detection workflow mdl
volume four and then bold it and then
look at
uh w day weekday is a function from
luber day
so it just looks at uh it wants me to
paste out
like the weekday for yesterday um
and then add the actual date and then
end the voting part
so what essentially comes out of this
is data non-detection in mpl volume 4
and then it basically
bolds that variable
um moving on the second part
um is and i guess i have to first
apologize to everyone
that's a true r person here um for the
use of this for loop
um so there's probably a better way to
write this with an apply function
but i guess bear with me for um for the
time being
um but basically um
uh what this does is it's writing this
loop
uh that goes through this uh previously
referenced data frame called anomalies
that essentially just is output of our
um um
uh of of that specific model
and has several columns to like tell us
like okay what is the
um what's the predicted value what's the
confidence interval like
um what's the actual value so um
essentially it just kind of
looks at that and goes through each of
those rows individually
and um again i'm making use of this uh
slack slack markdown so
for example i go in here and i paste i
paste in
uh well i guess
[Music]
uh this specific value of the
uh the confidence interval there and so
essentially trying to figure out like is
this a
a good anomaly where we have more or
less and then based on that
it uses this colon triangle up green
transparent colon
which is essentially a way to write an
emoji inside of
slack which the triangle of green
transparent is what you see here
and then trialing down red transparent
is the one that you see here
and then it just basically keeps
concatenating this thing out
until it gets to like that entire um the
end of the
the row here and then it just kind of
starts at the top and it runs through
every single
anomaly that we've detected for that
prior day
um the footer is pretty simple but we
actually found that this was
very important to add um so uh
many times we actually will add the
link to the business intelligence
dashboard inside of here so
we um we for everything that we post
into slack we try to give people a
um an option to actually um
dig in further if they'd like so we we
generally hit a
link the source of truth for that data
um like i said in many cases this will
be a bi dashboard
in this specific case uh it goes
directly to our slack um
oh sorry uh salesforce instance there uh
which has that
um mql volume uh that we're looking at
in this case
so um really there's two purposes so for
a stakeholder they can access the data
and then internally for my team it's
useful to actually as a starting point
to look into like these types of
anomalies
so usually what would happen is that if
if something gets
surfaced to us um you know having the
specific report
at the bottom uh is helpful because if
there's something that we want to look
into we can just click on it and you're
already kind of
in the process of um you know
analysis for it um again another um
another way of how we're trying to like
um
use this blackbaud to kind of spur uh
democratization of data and like really
kind of make people familiar with data
and if they want to
and dig deeper into it
now now that we've filled those three um
parts out so we have a vector with
message title we have a vector with
message body and then one with footer
um like the actual post request from the
httpr package is pretty simple right so
if i go into this one
um uh basically all we have to do
is uh write um write it in the
the syntax that you know we know from
that um
from that slack kit builder caveat here
if you're actually doing this and this
is all familiar to you and you've done
everything this before um this
attachment is actually um
this specific code here um is actually
not the newest way of writing this
anymore it's a bit different now
um but you know in times of uh when we
wrote this
this specific bot um you essentially
wanted to use this attachments function
um
they uh it's not completely deprecated
um but like uh it's it's sort of a
legacy way of doing it
so there's now also different ways of
using blocks
but uh so basically um uh like i said
uh we still uh have the same uh title
message footer and message body which is
just vectorized uh
um variables that i'm pushing uh into
here into like this
in this case uh turns out that the
message title so that
portion at the top um is actually a
thing called pretext footer footer and
then the message body is the actual
text portion and then i'm also passing
in this color
color indicator which is the color of
the um sort of the quotation indent
so you can change that as well um again
that is to say that there is a lot of
ways that you can customize this so you
could
one thing that we've done for example is
any time the code breaks
um we actually highlight that red um
you know where for this case this f2 f2
f2 uh hex color is just a gray bar
um so if i actually go in and i run this
code again uh
i get the same thing so like the status
200 here looks good
uh post me that response http response
thing there
um and um it turns out that
it would post it just like that and
slack
um cool um so that's a that's a text
based
um example right where we still all
um uh we're using basically exclusively
text
in order to um get an information across
um but i'm while i'm not going to go
like
sort of like deep into the code for the
next example like i did want to put a
slide on here
to show you that it is possible to do
different things
there so in this case uh you can put the
ggplot visualization for example
as an attachment uh into a slackbot
message
where in this case um you know this is
one where
we're tracking the daily um the daily
attainment of sales pipeline
um with and then we have actually have
some
uh year-over-year data so you can see uh
um
you know pipeline year-over-year and
then we're pacing out a target based on
a specific uh
like uh assumption uh so in this case
the target
we have a target that we're actually
pacing based off of
where how we're pacing last year um so
basically we can have a completely
custom visualization build inside of
ggblock
and push that into slot um which is
something that
i would wager to say is probably harder
to do in uh
in the bi tool since we can leverage
some of the models that we're building
already anyway
um a little disclaimer here at the
bottom
so um when you push images into slack
it actually requires a bit more um you
know uh
variables to be passed into this um
process so there's a specific block
token you'll have to pass
um but um that is to say it's not that
hard to figure out
and uh um it's all uh it's all possible
um you know for uh for someone with some
more skills
um so those are some examples um
now basically we're now at the spot
where
um you know if you think back of what i
did and obviously this is a presentation
so i kind of faked it away but
um really we haven't actually
automated or productionized anything so
at this point i have an r script that
you know essentially have to run every
time and then it does something for me
um so internally we actually use this
process
with our studio connect so we have a
most of our data sits inside of a
redshift instance
i say most um it's really just most it
could be anything we could hook
directly into into salesforce instances
there's some proprietary
proprietary systems that we have as we
uh grow like organically and
inorganically so we
tend to acquire other companies as well
they might have a different data stack
so
it could be different but basically if
for
a as a standardized process we have data
sitting somewhere
write some sql put that data into r or
python um and then we use r studio
connect
to kind of schedule that um
that process of running that r script um
on whatever cadence we wanted to run
note that if you don't have our studio
connect um you know we actually
previously used
we've previously done this um just with
the good old chrome tabs
uh so if you're uh you know if you have
like a unix box or anything
uh you and you you know you can show
into that and
um run our script on the schedule that
is the same process
um but for us uh from the eso fuse
perspective
uh many other reasons uh you know we
decided that our studio connect was a
good uh sort of intermediary uh that
would
um take care of all of the uh code
execution process
uh on the um on a recurring basis
so what this is actually look like so in
this case and this is again that daily
lead checker there
um so if you write your r code inside of
our markdown file
uh then you can just deploy that into
our studio connect and then essentially
schedule that
to execute whenever you wanted to
execute so you could run this
every five minutes if you wanted to um
the daily checker here
actually just runs every day for us um
you know at 12 15. the reason why that
is is because
um that our some of the etl processes
for us
uh end at 10 a.m uh uh pacific time so
that's
in my case i'm uh i'm in nashville so
this would be like
12 you know around noon so when we run
this i know all the etl processes have
refreshed i know i have the newest data
in the
data warehouse um and uh
um essentially that's when my um daily
new checker for the prior day
executes and it does so every week every
weekday
um and it hasn't failed yet so
i i'm pretty happy with that process um
so um to wrap this up um
you know it really like this whole thing
really is a win-win situation for us
so for the organization um you know in
terms of
democratizing data um this was really
fantastic because
um it really helped like both technical
and
non-technical marketers really get the
data that they needed
to make business savvy decisions
um we've had
numerous requests to build additional um
uh additional notifications out um very
very specified uh to individual people
um
so uh you know we could send um
you know a custom report to just one
individual
if we wanted to if they were interested
in one very specific data point
um and then uh for the analytics team
uh you know um while we are growing and
you know uh
where uh we have been growing and i
think we're going to hire some
additional uh
folks uh over the next couple months
um we're still a lean organization and
you know we support
different many many different
stakeholders um
so bandwidth is an issue for us where
uh we really have to do well in terms of
prioritizing which projects we
uh uh we work on with them that sort of
meet that
impact versus the effort uh kind of uh
calculation um but
before we implemented some implemented
some of these processes
um there was a lot of tech debt that we
had to do you know a lot of redundant
reporting tasks
um and uh the like so all of that is
we're able to automate away and with
that time save
um you know we can essentially
reallocate that to things that
we actually feel like are impactful um
so let's do more [ __ ] that's cool right
that's what we all want to do
um so uh that's the end um
that's where i am uh so i hope this was
useful or helpful to some people
um and yeah love to hear some questions
if there aren't
thank you so much matthias that was
awesome and
it's actually making me realize the
technology behind some of the slack bots
that we use
here at our studio too
there's a few questions in slido that
i'll go over too and then
if anyone wants to upvote other
questions or put other questions in
there
if there's anything we don't get to
today i'll be sure to send them over
to matthias as well if that's okay yeah
absolutely
um the first